this is Jocko underground podcast number
58 sitting here with Echo Charles Echo
Charles how long does it take to plan
a seal mission
30 minutes more less more more right
more than you have so this is a common
question that I used to ask the seals
it'd be like how long will it take you
to play on this Mission and guys guys
well we're four hours or six hours or
eight hours or one hour and the answer
actually is this is actually what the
answer is it's a half an hour longer
than the amount of time that you had to
plan the mission because that's what it
takes to get everything aligned you're
almost there then you gotta freaking
make some last minute adjustments now I
recently discovered there's a a theory a
law around this and it's actually called
Parkinson's law
and Parkinson's law what it states
is that work expands so as to fill the
time available for its completion
now in in a planning for like a single
mission
there's always a little bit extra do
that's why it expands Beyond it by about
a half an hour you give somebody 20
minutes to plan it's going to take them
50. you give them an hour it's going to
take an hour 30. so
this guy his name was Cyril Northcote
Parkinson he was a live born in 1909
lived in 1993 he was a naval historian
he was an author
and he served in the territorial armor
Army which is like the reserves over in
England
and he actually ended up teaching quite
a bit at school at military schools
but he made up this law and the law was
kind of and I I read through it it's
it's a spoof he's kind of making fun of
he's making fun of it right it's sort of
like my statement of like it takes a
half an hour like the theory is that it
takes one half hour longer than he he
that's what he that's what he's doing
too and he put a bunch of formulations
around it and and he made other ones but
you know the uh the number of new
employees hired annually over the number
of employees who want to be promoted by
hiring new employees he goes through all
these formulations they're funny and
that was for one of his other laws but
he just talks about how bureaucracies
form and how how they grow and what
their Effectiveness and efficiency is
but this particular law is interesting
and it's interesting to pay attention to
because it allows you to take some
control over time right and knowing that
if you can compress time
you can get more done do you let like
let's say I have a call with an East
Coast client that's at seven o'clock in
the morning it takes me a half an hour
you know to get done get showered
my workout I'm gonna be super efficient
and it's going to be a good freaking
workout yeah
and I'm gonna get I'm not gonna waste
any time I'm in there I'm getting it
yeah
if I have my first calls at nine bro my
workout's gonna take longer and it's not
going to be necessarily look sometimes
it's nice you go in there you get a
little bit of a better workout because
you have more time yeah but when you're
on a timeline you get more efficient
this also applies to
if you if you're going on a hike or
you're going on a mission and you have
whatever size rucksack you have it's
gonna get filled up so the bigger
rucksack you have the more crap you're
gonna bring
the more here's another one your house
the bigger your house is remember when
you had an apartment yep I do back in
the day back in the day yeah and you
didn't have a bunch of stuff nope you
had like very limited stuff now you got
a big house and you got a lot of stuff
with a garage too but with the garages
I've been in which is kind of filled up
with stuff as well do your cars fit in
your garage anymore they do now we uh
recently very recently just made the
decision to go hard and clear it out
yeah
so these if you put limitations on
yourself it can actually increase your
efficiency
if you set yourself up with a types
tight schedule it can drive your Tempo
it can drive your pace
if you give yourself unlimited time if
you give yourself unlimited resources
you're going to use all those resources
you're going to use all that time
constraints that you put on yourself are
very effective
uh you know I we're we're uh Nick Lavery
who's a special forces guy he's on the
podcast
he lost his leg
in Afghanistan and he's got one of his
legs as a prosthetic leg but one of the
things he talks about is that
when he puts his leg when he says look
when you have a prosthetic leg when you
put that leg on the the timer starts
because there's sweat gonna build up the
Skin's starting to get worn the you're
you're basically your body changes a
little bit over time you know you you
that you got to tighten that thing up
you either get swelling or you get
reduction and so all these things are
going on so when you put when he puts
his leg on he has XM you know it well
depending on the weather depending on
the temperature depending on the
activity he knows when he puts that leg
on he has got to take advantage of that
Mobility
and that is something all these things
that I'm talking about the reason I'm
talking about them is because they can
really help us if we understand
Parkinson's law
and we understand the hazards of
Parkinson's law then we can put things
into effect that will help us avoid
falling into that trap yeah
it makes sense
yeah the one of the
um
the things right is like the things
that's pretty specific it's like um I
don't know maybe okay you ever did this
or maybe your wife did this or maybe you
know someone who did this where that you
live with where it's like okay let's say
your house is kind of messy let's say
it's normal messy but someone's coming
over
and they're like oh I'm gonna be
there in 15 minutes and you start oh I
don't want them to see my mess right and
you start cleaning up bro that's like a
solid quick clean job you know it's kind
of the same thing it'd be not bad yeah
it'll yeah it'll probably be I mean in
my experience it's usually pretty solid
you know yeah because you gotta but it's
yes they're kind of the same thing it's
like oh the clock is running you're not
you're not Dilly dallying you're not
like going through drawers and be like
oh I remember this thing do I need it do
I not you're just making decisions yeah
one of the little quotes I saw around
this thing is if you wait to the last
minute it only takes a minute
exactly I don't appreciate that now one
thing that I I mess up I where I have a
problem is
I think I don't want to be late for
anything and therefore let's say I'm
coming to record the podcast and I'm
like okay I'm meeting Echo at 4 30 at
night okay 4 30 and I get done with a
call at four and I'm like you know what
I need gas and I can get I technically I
can get I can drive here stop or drive
to the gas station stop get gas and then
continue here and then
be here before 30 but there's like a one
percent chance that I'm here at 433 and
so I don't do it so I could have I cut
it cost me three minutes of being late
but it but now when I drive home
I waste 12 minutes going to the gas
station getting the gas filled and all
that stuff so I tend on the I need to do
a better job of just fitting stuff in
there yeah just get it done yeah just
hey look I'll be a little bit late but
no Factor deal with it like you were
late today
I could have gassed I could have gone to
the grocery store or whatever you know
what I'm saying yep you could have you
run away in time for us yes sir yeah
well well yeah but that's okay and then
there's this Factor too where it's kind
of along those lines as well where okay
you I'm assuming you never did this
because of your college experience that
I know about you weren't like this but I
was like this where let's say they're
like okay we've got this paper too and
it's two in two weeks you know this
paper is due and it's about this and
brought to me two weeks you only have to
start till next week you know like bruh
I could do it in one week and then one
week turns into like four days now you
have left you know to turn in four days
and then three days and then I have one
day to do it and I didn't even start
like I think that's a common thing for a
lot of college students it's definitely
a common thing and it is almost
embarrassing yeah for me
I would I would literally be like done
with stuff a week in advance like it was
so stupid yeah and that makes sense
because in this whole other thing but by
the way I'm not trying to like humble
brag I was a 28 year old man at this
point this was my job this wasn't I
wasn't going to a party I wasn't meeting
a girl after class or before class I
wasn't going drinking no I was a grown
man with kids a wife a house like this
was my job that's what I was doing so
they gave me an assignment I was like
okay cool let me get this done and
that's like and that was uh when you
told me all that I was like oh yeah that
makes sense because that's probably how
if I chose to or went back to college if
I chose to go back to college for
whatever reason that's how it would be
too where because it's when you're 18.
[Music]
in my case 17.
is this a newfound sense of Freedom
um party's like three times a week like
there's all this stuff that's like
you're not used to all these like works
and Liberties and benefits and Pleasures
that you're not necessarily used to so
they become these massive distractions
so all this class yeah you barely even
know why you're taking this class so
that's way on the back burner so all
this other stuff is like you know takes
precedence whatever but when you're 28
just like I said like no you got a wife
family you chose to be here you know why
you're there too and you're like bro I'm
and it's kind of easy when you look at
it that way like college I mean just
like high school it's the same thing but
depending on who you are but College in
and of itself is like
I don't say it's all colleges are easy
but I'm just saying like if you approach
it like that you'd be surprised how you
can fly through these things but
nonetheless it depends
um but not all of us are like that in
college so you get you know you
procrastinate all the way until the last
day you pull an all-nighter and you get
it done and get a good grade I've done
that more than once straight one time I
got a straight up a perfect score on a
paper that I did in one day two weeks it
was supposed to be how long was the
paper four pages
okay minor I can't even much credit for
that but still that's pretty easy I had
two weeks I did it one day yeah so but
all that did was kind of embolden me
further
so now next time I know they say two
weeks no problem one day you know so it
kind of can like perpetuate the bad
behavior in a small way you know if you
pull it off yeah don't do it don't do it
um there we go the bottom line is
constraints can be useful discipline
equals Freedom Parkinson's law know it
understand it don't fall into the Trap
of giving yourself a bunch of time
because you'll use it all and we we
don't have unlimited time
so you said something a couple times but
then you'll probably remember this that
it it actually impacted me a lot
the idea of things looming was that were
you recording or not I don't know I
don't think we're recording actually you
said you don't like I don't like things
things looming and paper that's due yeah
exactly so in a way the better way to
think of it is if I can procrastinate
for two weeks and actually get it done
in one days we'll say two days right
we'll see two
um if I can procrastinate two weeks and
get it done in two days why don't I just
go hard the first two days of the two
weeks yeah then I got two weeks to
cruise which I would be doing anyway but
now I don't have anything looming which
is a big deal me I'm loose I'm kind of
used to things looming not so much
anymore but looming you know that's just
a you know mental exercise right there
stay away from it you know but when the
looming goes away it's like this sense
of like relief it is a sense of relief
that's that's really nice it's probably
because I have a high level of
conscientiousness and you probably don't
that's that's what I think is probably
the trait that incurs
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground